das werde ich schon mal
heute ist der fünfte Tag an dem ich
versuche mich zu 100% selbst zu
versorgen und ich habe jetzt schon so
viel mehr Ehrfurcht vor Lebensmittel
Verschwendung als vorher erzählt bitte
euren Freunden von der Aktion mit dem
gelben Band da könnt ihr Obstbäume
markieren wenn ihr selber mit dem Ernten
nicht mehr hinterherkommt und andersrum
findet ihr so auch Obstbäume die er ab
ernten könnt wenn ihr selber keine habt
ich habe diese Leckereien hier aus den
Birnen hergestellt einmal bin Chips dann
habe ich Birnen gefüttert und eingekocht
ein Bären Birnen muss habe ich
eingekocht dann habe ich fruchtleder
hergestellt bin einfach eingelagert und
einen herrlichen birnenessig angesetzt